1989 was a great year for pop culture classics,
with blockbuster hits that helped to form
some of the fabric of our shared language
of references and influences.
It was also a full 30 years ago, and remembering
that while you’re watching an old favorite
might just make you feel like you’re crumbling
to dust as the credits roll.
The good news?
We’re here with some emotional support as
you remember that these movies were released
a full three decades ago.
In the 1980s, the only big-screen superhero
megastar was Superman, and the last major
live-action effort for Batman starred Adam
West.
Then came director Tim Burton, fresh off of
Beetlejuice, and an effort to capture some
of the more gothic Batman spirit made so popular
by the comics of the '70s and '80s.
The result was Tim Burton’s Batman, a massive
commercial hit and one of the most talked-about
films of 1989.
Michael Keaton starred as the Dark Knight,
which was a controversial casting choice at
the time, since he was mostly known for known
for goofy comedies.
It’s easy to argue that the real star was
Jack Nicholson as the Joker.
"Wait’ll they get a load of me."
Burton and designer Anton Furst imagined a
Gotham City that lives up to its name with
bold set design choices, memorable costumes,
a gorgeously lonesome Wayne Manor, and a sweeping
score from Danny Elfman that still resonates
as Batman’s signature theme.
The film has its flaws, including a rather
contrived origin for the Joker, but even today
it holds up as a classic of the genre.
Other Batman films have come since, some great
and some… not so well loved, but Burton's
film still holds a certain kind of sway over
'80s and '90s kids.
It spawned a franchise that would run for
a decade and remains one of the most influential
superhero films ever made.
In fact, virtually every comic book film of
the 1990s and even into the 2000s was a reaction
to it in some way.
The last film installment of the Friday the
13th franchise was an ill-fated reboot in
2009, so it might be difficult to remember
that this slasher series was once a box office
powerhouse.
Producers cranked out eight Friday films in
the 1980s, and quickly established Jason Voorhees'
reputation as an iconic killing machine who
just won't go away.
Jason Takes Manhattan is not the best of these
films, but it is among the most interesting.
It follows a group of high school seniors
who are all set to take a big trip up to the
Big Apple, but there's one problem: their
journey begins at Crystal Lake, where Jason
sank at the end of the last film.
He's reanimated by an electrical accident,
climbs aboard, and begins causing havoc.
Sadly, he only really "takes" Manhattan in
the final minutes, but in between there's
a brutal and often silly cruise that some
Friday fans love and others loathe.
Whether you dig the film or not, it remains
a fascinating cultural artifact in terms of
how far slasher franchises were willing to
go in the '80s to keep churning out sequels.
Rick Moranis hasn't made a major live-action
film appearance in more than 20 years, but
once upon a time he was a comedy powerhouse,
and Honey, I Shrunk the Kids was one of his
most successful showcases.
Moranis is a master of in-over-your-head,
nerdy comedy, and in that regard he was perhaps
never more perfectly cast than he is in this
film.
"Dianne, I've got something real important
to tell you."
"Are you trying to tell me the machine works?
Do the kids know?"
"Well, yeah, the kids know."
"That's great!"
Suburban dad and amateur inventor Wayne Szalinski
has created a shrink ray that never seems
to quite work, until the day it accidentally
shrinks the Szalinski kids and their neighbors,
the Thompson children.
While Wayne and his wife Diane try desperately
to find the kids while keeping the incident
under wraps, the kids themselves embark on
an epic journey through the back yard.
Kids of a certain age watched this film over
and over when it hit home video.
The middle entry into the Back to the Future
seems half-forgotten by some viewers, stuck
between "the original" and "the one where
they go to the Old West," but in many ways,
Back to the Future Part II is the most interesting
of the three films.
For one thing, it's the only one of the three
that imagines a version of "the future”
of 2015 rather than jumping to the past, and
for another, that future is just bonkers.
"Hydrate level four please."
Though it's definitely weaker than its predecessor,
Part II is full of instantly memorable moments,
from the introduction of the hoverboard to
Biff's lair in the bad timeline to the ridiculous
fashion choices of "2015."
Plus, we will never stop making jokes about
the power of sports almanacs because of this
movie.
With one line, Field of Dreams cemented its
place in the pop culture lexicon as one of
the most quoted films ever made.
"If you build it, he will come."
Really, though this movie is so much more
than a memorable phrase.
It’s a sweeping declaration of American
optimism, and the kind of movie that will
make even the most die-hard baseball haters
in your life fall in love with the game, if
only for a little while.
Field of Dreams didn't need the benefit of
time for people to recognize its greatness.
It was nominated for three Oscars after its
release, including Best Picture, and immediately
became the kind of film certain families wanted
to rent on home video again and again.
In the years since, it's become the kind of
basic cable staple on which pretty much everyone
in the living room can agree, and even if
you're seeing it for the hundredth time, there's
a certain kind of magic in its simplicity.
"Is this heaven?"
"It’s Iowa."
Even the worst Star Trek films are still interesting
in their ambition, and Star Trek V: The Final
Frontier is perhaps the best example of this.
Directed by William Shatner, the film chronicles
the Enterprise crew's involvement in a quest
to find "God" in a mystical location somewhere
in the center of the galaxy.
It's a big idea, and even though the results
have earned it a reputation among some Trek
fans as the single worst piece of the entire
franchise, it has its moments.
"Excuse me, I’d just like to ask a question?
What does God need with a Starship?"
Of course, that power is masked by questionable
directing choices, subpar visual effects,
and a high concept that just kind of fizzles
out by the end.
Despite all that, it still maintains a sense
of personality that makes it pretty watchable.
Captain Kirk climbing a mountain and hanging
out with Spock and Bones around a campfire
together just works.
Stephen King adaptations are culturally ubiquitous,
and they have been for decades.
The man's work is so popular among film producers
that he's launched whole franchises from a
single short story, and filmmakers are often
so eager to capitalize on his name that they'll
only very loosely tie their stories to his
concepts.
We’re looking at you here, Lawnmower Man.
When an adaptation works, though, it really
works, and Pet Sematary is definitely one
of those.
The film famously tells the story of a family
who moves into a new house near a pet cemetery
set up by the local children to bury the animals
who are hit by cars on the dangerous nearby
road.
When the family cat dies, he's buried it the
Native American burial ground beyond the pet
cemetery, only to be brought back to life,
in a manner of speaking, by the land's mysterious
powers.
Then the family's young son is killed… and
the rest is the stuff of nightmares.
The climactic scares of Pet Sematary are still
among the most memorable of any horror film
released in the 1980s, and the story is so
powerful that it's easy to see why a remake
is hitting theaters this spring.
For a very long time, Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade was the final entry in the whip-cracking
adventure franchise and served as the perfect
way for Indy to quite literally ride into
the sunset.
After the misstep of The Temple of Doom, filmmakers
George Lucas and Steven Spielberg returned
to the trope of Indy searching for fabled
religious artifacts and punching out Nazis,
and sent him after the “Holy Grail” of
ancient artifacts, which in this case was
the literal Holy Grail.
"Germany has declared war on the Jones boys!"
The result is a film that's not quite as good
as the first, because Raiders of the Lost
Ark is basically perfect, and something that
still holds up three decades later.
The chemistry between Indy and his father,
Henry Jones Sr, played by the great Sean Connery,
is perfect, and while It's not quite the action
masterpiece that Raiders was, it's still great
adventure fun.
Plus, it made us say “he chose… poorly”
forever, even if we were just talking about
pizza toppings.
The canon of great teen comedies of the 1980s
is vast and varied.
You have your unrepentant sex comedies like
Porky's, your slightly more contemplative
fare like Sixteen Candles, your dramedies
like The Breakfast Club, and plenty of other
movies that easily fit into a genre, or even
bounce between a few of them.
Then you've got Heathers, which is something
all its own.
"I've cut off Heather Chandler's head and
Heather Duke's head has sprouted back in its
place."
Heathers took the sense of aggression and
venom that was bubbling under the surface
of so many other teen comedies and put it
front and center, creating a deliciously nasty
brew that's as brutal as it is brutally hilarious.
Winona Ryder gives one of the best performances
of her career, and the film cemented Christian
Slater and Shannen Doherty as icons of their
era.
Though its box office left something to be
desired, it became one of the most important
cult films of the early '90s video market.
We're still feeling its influence today in
everything from horror movies to YA novels
to its own TV remake.
Speaking of teen comedies from the '80s that
are in a class by themselves, there's Bill
and Ted's Excellent Adventure, a film that
combines slacker culture with time travel.
If you haven't seen it, the results are exactly
as weird as you'd expect.
"Ted?"
"What?"
"This has been a most unusual day."
The great thing about Bill and Ted, and what's
allowed it to hold up as well as it has for
30 years, is the very real sense of sincerity
running throughout the film.
It delivers the time travel goods and the
slacker comedy goods simultaneously, and it
somehow manages to combine all of that with
a kind of wish fulfillment as the boys gather
a cadre of historical figures together and
cram them into a time-traveling phone booth.
Most importantly, though, there's a tremendous
self-awareness running through the film that
allows Bill and Ted to be both genuinely likable
and viciously self-deprecating at the same
time.
It's a deceptively simple movie with some
very complex comedy running through it.
Oh, and it makes you want to bust out your
best air guitar.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.